[Musique]
le geste est soigné david bretagne
peaufine sa création cette maquette lui
a pris beaucoup de temps
nous avons mis à peu près deux mois pour
élaborer le projet et c'est aussi un
gros challenge pour nous relevant nous
arrivons ici le vendredi soir et il faut
que le décor soit prêt pour le samedi
là je suis en train de faire le montage
pour le
pour le rush de mettre un poteau
supplémentaires ambulanciers la journée
le soir il prend soin de ses 5000
figurines à 47 ans est un mordu de
playmobil maintenant j'en chante
connection j'ai pas pu en avoir quand
j'étais enfant donc c'est je me reproche
est un petit peu dans l'enfance avec ce
que je pas pu ratisser le fait
d'échanger avec d'autres collectionneurs
comme il y en a assez des pièces de
monnaie dos et des canettes nous c'est
l'épiné puis on permet de créer nos
histoires et de les mettre en scène une
passion qui lui coûtent plus d'une
centaine d'euros par mois
un peu plus loin cette famille vient
élargir la collection d'animaux
playmobil du petit esteban huit ans
[Musique]
total de la mare des vaches des poules
et cochons
tant qu'il y aura de la place dans sa
chambre je pense qu'on laissera faire et
puis bah après on verra s'il fera
grandir mais bon non pour l'instant ça
va
il encore de la place dans la chambre
c'est bon parmi des exposants certains
viennent de très loin comme gustave
originaire d'hanovre en allemagne 43 ans
dont 23 passés dans l'univers playmobil
j'ai commencé à les acheter 20 and pour
collectionner les mobiles
je suis fou de playmobil pourquoi vous
êtes soudainement c'est une grande
passion et c'est très bien être avec
tous les amis dans tout l'europe
spécialement en france
l'exposition aux aidants gillon aura
réuni plus de 4000 personnes en deux
jours
[Musique]